so you're playing Edith's tolki and
she's an incredibly important figure in
his life can you talk about the sense of
responsibility that you felt taking on
the role yeah I I had obviously known
Tolkien's work before signing on to this
but I was very unaware of Edith and her
influence on him as I think a lot of
people are there's very little research
I could really do on her because there's
a few photographs and obviously limited
information but the idea that she
inspired so many of the characters
mostly obviously the elven characters
and Beren and lúthien story but the
sense that she encouraged him to
continue telling these stories was
really exciting for me because without I
think her influence we may not even have
the Hobbit or Lord of the Rings or any
of those so but also having very little
to go off of there wasn't too much eye
pressure in terms of everyone knowing
someone specifically that I had to then
like create there was a freedom with her
that I got to explore which I loved you
brought up the fact that she inspired a
lot of characters particularly lúthien
and then Arwen who we do know from the
Lord of the ranch eyes and you get to do
that beautiful scene where you're
dancing and we know that Baron and
Aragorn both met their elven
counterparts dancing in the forest yeah
what was it like to be able to portray
that cuz that's not something we've seen
in the movies right it was funny because
dome a said to me just you know elven
dance right okay but like what does that
mean he's like just it's you know
fantastical and magical and I thought
well I guess like Florence is kind of
like that from Florence machine she's
very magnetic to watch and very like
kind of mad she's magical so I thought
well maybe there's that elephant just
moving your head you know just being
quite with the trees and one with nature
I guess and so that was it was beautiful
though because it's these snippets that
were very inspiring to him and I loved
the fact that they didn't require words
it really was it was dancing it was
movement it was just the way that she
was connected to herself in her
environment that he was so that he
responded so well to
and I think that was so much about their
relationship in general is that they
didn't necessarily need to use words in
order to inspire one another that's
really beautiful I think maybe people
watching this who aren't familiar with
you will be surprised to learn that
you're not English right what was it
like taking on the dialect and working
with the primarily English casting group
I well I was actually born here but I
sound like this now but I've done I've
used an English accent for a couple
things now and but they're all different
dialects so it's quite specific this was
a very specific dialect but it was great
being surrounded by the Brits every day
because I could easily fall into it and
it's a it's a story that required being
shot in Europe and with Brits and there
it was just it felt very natural to have
that so the final question I want to ask
you I love to ask actors this is what is
the one scene or the one moment that you
want everyone watching this to look out
for when they see tokine
I love the Barrows bookshop scene so I'm
not even in it with Nick and all the
fellowship all the boys I think because
the the friendship element to this story
is what was so pivotal in his creation
of all the stories and his encouragement
of yes edith of course encouraged him to
do this but the friendship and the
fellowship even just the name fellowship
i mean it's it's the it's the genesis of
where it all came from and i think the
chemistry with all the boys was so
magnetic that all those boroughs
bookshop scenes where you can see
talking connecting the dots and creating
these characters and this this
Brotherhood that that helped really
create who he became as a man years
later I think is so important to know
for the creation of the story so I think
those scenes are wonderful and the
actors are so great that's really
Genesis for you to mention scenes that
you're not even a part of yeah like I
loved watching those I was like these
are great Edith is in one of them but
I'm like this is important to watch yeah
you